so huge news involving rudy giuliani  apparently the department of justice has  executed a search warrant and  searched his files it's hard to  overstate just  how extraordinary of a step this is the  department of justice doesn't like  executing search warrants against  lawyers and especially against lawyers  of a former president it was  extraordinary when it happened to  michael cohen and it's doubly  extraordinary when it happens to rudy  giuliani this is allegedly related to  giuliani's efforts to illegally lobby on  behalf  of ukrainians and potentially russians  and surprise surprise there are reports  that the trump doj tried to quash this  investigation  only to have new attorney general  merrick garland remove the objections  whether this is the start of  prosecutions against former trump  officials or just something related to  giuliani  remains to be seen but we'll see you in  court